what if all life on Earth died and now
we fast forward a billion years
what would be the traces left it so the
question I'm trying to ask is if life
had existed on Mars what would be the
signs we would look for that's a very
good question the thing is that if you
draw the parallel with Earth it took 82
percent of Earth's history
geological history to go from very
simple life microbial life to complexity
and when I'm saying complexity I'm not
even talking about us I'm talking about
animals so Marcy smaller lost its
magnetic field very fast and lost his
atmosphere is very fast
life also
appeared on Earth very fast so the
condition being quite similar at that
time between the Earth and Mars let's
assumed for a moment that life appeared
on Mars it would have been Simple Life
when conditions started to degrade which
was less than a billion year after the
planet had formed so everything at the
surface
would have disappeared except maybe for
morphological traces of the interaction
between life and its environment so on
Earth the best example are what we call
stromatolites these are rock formation
that are built by microbes so we know
that we we know how to recognize them
you could have chemical traces as well
there is some interesting question marks
right now about carbon Isotopes at
Crater because we found an abundance of
C12 which normally is used by life on
Earth but it can produce be produced by
other things so it's not that it's a
real bio signature in itself but it's
intriguing we have now the C12 and we
have methane but uh going back it's a
Time on Mars 3.5 billion years ago where
you have lots of distractions where you
have lots of impact cratering Etc so but
we still have very old rocks that are
that survive from that time so these are
good uh good places that's why we're
sending the Rovers in those places
ancient lakes and impact craters and and
places where you have very old rocks So
when you say ancient lakes and impact
craters the simple question so impact
Creator is a Creator created by a giant
rock hitting the planet and yes a big
rock that can be metal or rock or it can
be a comet as well mostly eyes so is
that good for life or bad for life
it's actually both
um interestingly enough the building
blocks of life the bricks the stuff we
are made of carbon hydrogen oxygen and
nitrogen and phosphorus they were
included
on our planet they were built in just
because our planet is made of this kind
of rocks asteroids and comets coming
together by what we call a Christian so
they were built in when an asteroid
comes there is a lot of Destruction
going on but at the same time those
rocks they bring with them those bricks
of life and they create lots of energy
and if the environment around is
favorable you might possibly be have
some sitting going on that's one of the
aspect of what we call panspermia which
is the fact that comets and asteroid
have the building blocks of life and
better than them and that given
favorable condition they might be able
to see planets this is a theory